Indonesia is sometimes considered a
moderate Muslim nation a sort of Muslim
country success story of sorts and we've
pointed out before that that's not
exactly accurate for example there's a
pretty high prevalence of Muslim based
female genital mutilation in Indonesia
that's one example it appears to be
getting worse Indonesian police seem to
now be participating in terrorizing the
gay community the Islamic community of
Indonesia the Islamist community of
Indonesia has been interested in making
homosexuality illegal for a while now
like for example the Islamic Defenders
from fpi it I'm sorry the Islamic
Defenders Front which is also known as
FBI and it now appears that the police
are sort of patrolling for gay people in
May officers detained over a hundred and
forty men in a raid on the Atlantis
sauna and they accused them of being
involved in a gay prostitution ring in a
part of Jakarta that's also home to many
heterosexual spas as well a month
earlier police raided a hotel in
Indonesia's second-biggest city of
Surabaya over an alleged sex party and
they made the 14 men that they detained
undergo HIV tests before they publicly
released the results according to local
media reports the men who were detained
at that Atlantis sauna were nearly all
later released without any charges but
first they were strip searched
photographed and marched half-naked from
the venue into vehicles and in addition
photographs of them were then shared on
social media now previously or I guess
to set the stage other than in the very
extremists akshay province in Indonesia
homosexuality is strictly speaking legal
in the country but it's pretty taboo
which is why the gay community will
often end up gathering in these private
you know underground parties at some of
these saunas etc there was a Pew
Research Center poll back in 2013 which
found that 93 percent of respondents in
Indonesia disagreed that society should
homosexuality so despite the strict
legality in most of the country it's
still not looked upon very favorably by
the Indonesian community there is still
a lot to be concerned about if you're a
gay person in much of Indonesia and in
much of the world and this is a horrible
horrible story we've talked about what's
been going on in Chechnya with the gay
community and it's really important if
you live in the United States you might
think well gay marriage is legal now so
LGBT rights are no longer an issue
number one even in the United States
you've got many states where you can
fire someone merely because of their
sexual orientation in the United States
you have this new sort of front in the
fight against LGBT rights which is
so-called religious freedom bills which
which we've seen but in a lot of the
world it is even worse than it is
in the United States and I'll go even
further which is that if you continue to
see this movement on the right that's
all about religious rights and whatever
else the case may be
you may end up with a situation that is
incredibly insidious in in terms of how
it will oppress LGBT rights because it
will all be done under the guise of
strict religious freedom and
constitutionality that was sort of
attempted with gay marriage hey it's not
it's not constitutional gay marriage
isn't constitutional and obviously that
wasn't the case and the Supreme Court
has had their day on that but now you
will see and you were already seeing
this direct argument made that it is a
religiously protected by the
Constitution right to discriminate
against LGBT individuals and sadly
there's been a tension that has been
pulled away from the LGBT rights issue
since that Supreme Court decision what
was it it was it not last summer but the
Sony before 2015 right yeah two years
ago at this point it's sort of like when
Obama became president there was a
faction of the u.s. that said racism is
over because a half black guy's
president there's also a faction of
Americans who believe the concern over
LGBT rights ended the day that the
Supreme Court said no more state bans on
same-sex marriage absol
lutely not absolutely not the case
today's program is made possible in part
by Gamefly which is sort of like netflix
for video games they've got over 8,000
new and classic games for xbox one Xbox
360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can also stream games
you don't even need a gaming console or
a computer because you can stream games
through your Amazon fire stick or Roku
box and then use your mobile phone as
the controller you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price never with due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a 30-day free
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games I think I mentioned that you can
also rent games through the mobile app
get a free 30 day trial for david pakman
show viewers and listeners and support
our show at Gamefly offer.com forward
slash TDP s